Protestors took to the streets of Hong Kong
beginning in April 2019, shortly after the
Hong Kong government proposed a bill permitting
extradition to China.
Since then, Hong Kong Chief Executive Carrie
Lam (a position appointed by Beijing) has
pledged to withdraw the bill.
But the antigovernment protests have evolved
past this issue
and protestors are now demanding more democratic
freedoms in Hong Kong.
Honestly, it is hard to see how this will
all end.
Even if Carrie Lam gets the boot, that's probably
not enough to satisfy protestors.
And it seems equally unlikely that Beijing
will yield to their demands.
The Chinese Communist Party does not want
to encourage similar behavior in other regions
problematic to the regime.
The CCP also wants to show Taiwan that the
one country, two systems formula works.
So far, China has avoided a Tiananmen-style crackdown,
opting instead for repressive police tactics.
Chinese president Xi Jinping has also
warned that anyone attempting
to split China would be crushed.
How the Communist Party decides to ultimately
address the protests may change the course
of China’s relationship with Hong Kong forever.
Which side do you think will ultimately get its way?
Let us know in our poll.
Also let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.